okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planning committee meeting
my name is council peter richards and i
will be chairing tonight's meeting i'm
going to run through a few housekeeping
things i may first of all
as you know from yesterday's vote in
parliament we are now obliged to wear
our masks inside and please if you can
uh remain as socially distant as you
possibly can within the chamber um only
when you are speaking will you be
allowed to take off your mask that
applies to everyone sat around this
table and also to our speakers
uh so please by that in mind when you do
sit down so if you could sit the middle
desk uh for our speakers there are some
hand sanitizing gel um i think we've got
some desk swat desk wipes if we haven't
we will put some there shortly in a bin
to put them in if once you're done if
you give the desk a quick wipe and the
the microphone buttons as well that
would be really appreciated
we're not expecting a fire alarm tonight
so if the one does go off follow us uh
we will be meeting over the car park uh
over the road please do make sure you're
over there so that we can make sure that
everyone is safely out of the building
we do need to make sure you're all
ticked off um mobile phones if you could
please turn them off uh at the very
least please turn them to silent i don't
mind if they're on and being used
provided that it doesn't affect uh the
running of this meeting
and we are of course as i'm sure you
know uh being live streamed and recorded
for future use on youtube and our
website as well we do have some officers
that are joining us online and i will go
through a list of those now so
introductions first of all so to my
immediate right we have ann banks from
committee services um joining us online
is our solicitor ross chambers and then
our planners are luis casey heather
kenny and joining us online is paul
thompson and to my immediate left is
dale barker who is our planning manager
dale do you have a statement you need to
make yes thank you chairman my role
tonight is to provide impartial advice
and to us assist members in their
decision taking thank you chair
thank you dale um
okay let's get into the meeting proper
could i have our apologies for
happenings please
yes chairman got apologies from
councillors fleming
crump
yes mr chairman um mr chairman uh
application um seven on the agenda
that's a warning barn can't blame
um
i was actually at the um parish council
meeting where it was discussed but um i
didn't make any comment on it so i come
here with a an open mind thank you mr
chairman
okay thank you very much council dixon
thank you chairman uh item four of the
agenda mega pardon item five of the
agenda which is application 21-02-771
i'm supporting that application and
we'll leave the committee at that point
and speak on behalf lovely thank you
very much anyone else any other members
for the disclosure
no jolly good okay uh minutes is
everyone happy with the minutes from the
24th of november a quick nod and yeah
all good that's lots of thumbs up so
that's been agreed mamas are signing
those after tonight's meeting
now we have a slight rejig of the
running order um we have two items that
have been triggered to committee due to
parish council either support or
objection um those parish councils
either haven't registered to speak or
now are unable to attend this evening so
the first item is
21.01708 rem that is application four on
or sorry item four on the agenda uh
fosway uh the old foss way
treadington
um
we would be looking to delegate that as
we haven't uh we do not have parish
council religious speak could i please
have a show of those in favor of
delegating
that is unanimous so committee therefore
delegates that item and item eight which
is application reference twenty one zero
two zero two one ful twenty eight farley
avenue in a harbory uh we did have a
parish council register to speak but
unfortunately they are no longer able to
make it tonight um we were informed
quite late so uh we will be looking to
delegate that as well could i please
have a show of hands for those in favor
of delegation for that item
marvelous committee therefore resolves
to delegate item
for the eight of the applicants i can do
that it's no problem so on item four um
it is to grant that is the foss way old
fastway in treadington and for item
eight uh again it is to grant uh 28
farley avenue
those those items as i say will be
delegated okay let's move then to our
first
official and uh full application which
is item number five uh application
reference is 2102 771 ful as mearwood
farm in solihull are presenting officer
is paul thompson who is online paul
whenever you are set up ready to go
please do feel free to start
thank you chair
good evening ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
um
on your screen just now
it should be the presentation
uh so we are here in earlswood
um
the application site is outlined in red
here it is a farm
uh the entirety of the site apart from a
small segment roughly here if you can
see my mouse pointer
is within the draft built up area
boundary for ellswood that uh since the
ndp has yet to be adopted that uh built
a very boundary has not been defined yet
um but the case officer has concluded
that because it has been um previously
developed at some point with paving
slabs it is to be treated as being
within the physical confines of the
village
um there are
five buildings uh currently on site five
barns there is a paddock
an orchard to the rear here outlined in
blues also within the ownership of the
applicant
uh
proposed here are three dwellings uh
this is to replace an earlier planning
permission for two dwellings um within
the same site
the floor plans are as follows uh
the main difference is there are now
five bedrooms as opposed to the
previously approved four
and here are the elevations
and the case officer's recommendation is
to grant planning commission chair
paul thank you so much indeed okay if we
could call forward our first speaker who
is councillor john brown
from the parish council from tamworth
and arden parish council
is our parish councillor here
hang on uh sorry councillor dixon if you
come forward and speak at one of my
friends otherwise we won't be able to
pick it up online
chairman i was advised by the parish
office yesterday that uh mr belton was
ill but they had sent in a written
report that we would have been speaking
to if it's not been received then
obviously you can't read it
unfortunately it hasn't been received so
we will not be able to uh receive it uh
if you could please clean the microphone
and uh when you make your way back over
that'd be great um i need to seek some
advice just bear with me
uh members in uh in the circumstances uh
given we have no uh parish council and
they are the reason that this has been
triggered to committee we're in a
position where we can once again
delegate um
excuse me bear with me a second
i'll start that again
we are in a position where we can once
again delegate due to the fact that the
trigger the parish council are not here
and in attendance so um could i please
have a show of hands for those in favor
of granting um through delegation for
this item please
that is unanimous so uh committee there
for resolves to delegate the granting of
application 2102 771 fuel millwood farm
this is running along very smoothly
okay so we'll move on to our next full
item
which is application 2100 496 lbc
the old toft bridge street and fenney
compton our presenting officer is
heather kenny heather whenever you're
ready over to you
thank you chair
the application for four members is for
the installation of solar panels to the
grade two listed building old top
oh it's on
sorry can you hear me
i'll start again the application for
members is for the installation of solar
panels to the grade ii listed building
altaft located in fenicompton
the building is identified by the yellow
dot the red line encircles the property
boundary
the building fronts directly onto the
road with garden land to the rear it
forms a group with the nearby list of
buildings also highlighted red and it
lies within the fanny compton
conservation area which is the pink
boundary line you can see here
the building is a linear range of late
17th century date with later extensions
to the side and rear
coast iron stone construction with
concrete tile roof the image you can see
now is the front of the building that's
taken from the road
this image is taken from the rear garden
which shows the elevation to which the
panels would be installed
and that's the second photo just to show
the left side of that elevation that was
obscured before
the solar panel array would be installed
in two parts across the roof plane on
this elevation
the panels would be placed both
horizontally and vertically arranged
around existing dormer and roof lights
the panels would sit on a frame over the
roof tiles which would be fixed to the
roof structure underneath
and the images now shown are the rear
lever elevation as it is currently next
to the proposed plan of the solar panel
installation the recommendation is that
consent be refused for this application
for the reasons set out in the officer
report
thank you very much uh we will move to
our first speaker registered on this
item who is mr stephen grierly who is
our applicant good evening and welcome
so mr burleigh you will have three
minutes i'll give you 30 second warning
before your time is up if you uh when
you're settled and ready if you press
the button in the middle it should turn
red and as soon as you're comfortable
feel free to start
members of the committee
our primary motivation for this
application is to substantially reduce
our household carbon footprint
saving over a thousand kilos of co2
annually almost half of our current
household demand
the planning office's report indicates
that this is a modest contribution to
the environmental change that we face
however it is only through millions of
modest actions that we can collectively
meet the target
of reducing uk emissions by a minimum of
78 percent by 2035.
an optimized solar array in combination
with other big-ticket items that have
already been
adopted
insulation secondary glazing electric
car
is critical for us to support limited
global warming to below two degrees
alternative options to mounting the
array on the main roof have been
evaluated
and are sub-optimal
shading significantly reduces system
performance on single-story extension
amount by 70 percent
on ground amount by 55
the size of a ground array is not suited
to resent residential garden currently
used by kids
greenhouse vegetable patch etcetera
mounting array on a single store
extension will be visible from uh bridge
street
the proposed mount on the rear facing
main roof around the existing dome or
window and velox windows is optimal it
maximizes system performance
it's only visible from the neighboring
knott's cottage
who are supported by the application
it's fully removable with the exception
of small holes in the drill into the
rafters
a full structural survey would be a
condition of planning being granted
no have been received and is actively
supported by neighbours
the declaration of a climate emergency
resulted in many councils revisiting
their planning guidelines recognizing
the environmental benefit can outweigh
the impact on the heritage of the
building
panels have been approved for
installation of grade one listed church
in google's book
and following houston towns council's
declarations of a climate emergency they
have approved panels for application on
their guild hall which is grade two
listed
we believe owning a listed building is
about holding onto the building's
features and history whilst not holding
it back from being future proof
holstoft has had a number of major
challenges during its lifetime
including joining two cottages together
a government planning inspector overall
birmingham city council's refusal to
grant permission for panels on a church
in mosley
stating in the context of a building
whose special architectural and historic
interest has been largely defined by a
series of changes
it seems to me that the panels would
really represent another addition to
that series
change is not necessarily harmful
my family has the desire and funds to
meet this challenge and do not feel that
owning a listed building should preclude
us from taking a large stride towards
our net zero goal 30 seconds
we believe that the environmental and
ecological benefits of the proposal
support both our personal and the
council's commitment to swiftly respond
to the climate emergency and it
significantly outweighs the limited
visual and heritage impact on the rear
of the building
thank you
beautifully time thank you very much if
you remain seated when i seek if there
are any questions from our members
members do we have any questions
councilman mills first please
thanks michelle uh
good evening um
the the uh
extension on the side
that's
was that part of the original building
essentially got there in white
um
it was it was there but the point the
two cottages would join together so this
is way predating when we owned it uh
we've brought it out but that wasn't
obviously it wasn't an original
part of the building when they were yeah
and
the
you've got a conservatory at the back
there yes that's just had planning
planning permission approved to be
knocked down and replaced with an
extension to the kichi
which is
the piece that juts out from the back
right okay thank you very much okay
counselor curtis please
thank you chair uh thank you mr really
um just a small question about the the
roof lights and the door mode do you
know if they were part of the original
structure or when they were put in uh
they were put in a point the um the two
cottages were knocked together so that
was um
roughly 1997 something like that yeah so
they're not part of the original anyway
thank you thank you
okay any further questions members last
chance no mr burley thank you very much
for your time and contribution this
evening if you yeah if you could fix
your mask and if you wouldn't mind doing
the quick wipe down when you have a
moment that would be great thank you
very much
while you're doing that i'll introduce
our next speaker who is counselor rock
council rock if you want to make your
way forward once mr burley has left the
seat that would be great
thank you and good evening and welcome
councillor rock you already know the
drill i'm sure you'll have five minutes
i'll give you a 30-second warning once
you're set and settled
feel free to start
thank you very much
good evening uh colleagues
uh
firstly can i say i've got no criticism
of officers in their work to preserve
our important
stock of heritage buildings and i regard
that as a valuable task
however i think we should be looking at
the balance in the present context of
climate change
i think this is the first case like this
that the council has come across since
its climate change emergency on uh was
passed on the 15th of july 2019 and the
uk parliament declared a climate
emergency on the 1st of may 2019.
first of all just want to make a comment
on the references in the report
missing from the report is the existence
of the emergency fund emerging penny
compton naval development plan although
i accept its limited weight
i know there are various references to
national precedence which seem to be
much earlier cases
i don't intend to repeat everything the
applicant has said but note in the
mosley case it does seem that the
planning context as nationally is
shifting
oh i see we've got the first slide
climate change is not a theory in fenney
compton
the village has been a victim of
increasing flooding problems over the
past several years
indeed the emerging neighborhood
development plan which is about to go to
regulation 16 consultation makes
specific reference to this issue 74 of
residents felt the development should
make more use of domestic solar power
and 71 of residents felt that minimizing
the risk of flooding was very important
now i'm not suggesting
that saving one or one and a half tons
of carbon dioxide in one development is
going to stop flooding
but if we could all save 30 million
tonnes of carbon dioxide by every home
in the uk having solar panels i think
this would make a difference
could have the next slide please
the pictures i showed you were taken
from the vicinity of bridge street where
this property is located
uh and these two are from the uh draft
neighborhood development plan
the chap standing up to his knees is
standing at the end of bridge street and
i think this does
add spice to preserve and enhance which
is the words in the nppf and in cs8
so turning to the report
the report in page 32 in the fourth
paragraph
suggests that public benefits must be
weighed against the level of harm
so that's a job for your committee now
in paragraph seven and eight on the same
page reference is made to the appearance
of the result this application
the views are entirely private and they
can't see by
officer
on the last paragraph of page 33 the
alternative of the ground or outbuilding
mounted system
will not deliver the climate change
benefits because of shading from a tree
and it's therefore not worth doing and
we're not about to cut a tree down so we
can do that
on page 34
uh paragraph three the report alludes to
another case which i believe is a solar
farm with a significant level of public
objection about the appearance of the
public realm
so
i want to be fair to officers but i
would question the validity
of such a comparison
where we have a lot of public support as
you've seen from your update sheets
i note that in january this year an
appeal was allowed to enlisted building
in the conservation zone next door in
farnborough
which included a substantial extension
but specifically include the
incorporation of roof lights visible
from the public domain the inspector
noted that the council deemed roof
lights acceptable before going on to
permit that additional substantial
change to the fabric of the building
the minimal harm presented by this
proposal is readily outweighed by the
climate change benefits and should be
considered in the round
not only because what has gone on at
cop26 and in parliament but and the
council's own resolutions
there are clear public benefits
the visual effects are only private
views the installation is clearly
reversible on unlike say velox windows
which seem we seem happier to permit and
both parliament and this council have
expressed a policy stance in resisting
climate change
the structural assessment should be
conditioned in the approval to address
their reservations about that feature
i ask that you grant this application
thank you
thank you very much counselor rock
members do we have any questions for our
counsellor please
answer adam
thank you counselor um just there there
are a couple of things in the in the
report which um
seem to have question marks over them
things like the sort of installation of
it being um reversible and the impact to
the structure and things like that do
you
have any experience from
the the might sort of lend to your views
i know you sort of made some assertions
there i just want to make sure that
there are
there's some basis to it
okay sorry cancer rock is your mic on
thank you chad unfortunately we missed
all of that
well i say we we we heard it yes but the
public didn't
rely on me remembering what i said so
shall i return to the holes then yeah i
mean you can just praise it if you
wouldn't mind so i think that the the
drilling the drilling of the holes is
clearly something that needs to be done
i would argue that that's not
substantial harm compared with other
things that we permit unlisted buildings
and in terms of the roof structure i
think that is something that can be met
as i said by condition uh
to make sure a structural assessment is
done and that's a technical matter but i
think that could be conditioned thank
you chairman
thank you very much members do we have
any other questions for councillor rock
no in our case cass rock thank you very
much for your time contribution i see
you're already cleaning up after
yourself
good man thank you okay uh members we
have no more speakers so um we will open
up two uh officers uh sorry questions to
officers or any points of clarification
we did have um one from council mills
about the extension um and timing of
that could you give us an idea of when
that was please
yes if i just go back to this photograph
there's a break in the stone work here
so you can see that it is a later
edition
i don't think it's late 20th century it
might be early 20th century or a 19th
century edition but it isn't part of the
original 17th century structure and
neither is the dormer or the ray flights
so so it's not recent reason
no okay
what you're saying is it's likely to
have been before the listing was put in
place it's not fair
yes the building was listed i believe i
don't think i've got the date oh in this
in 1967
so it is likely to have been in place
then but i couldn't say for definite
without
doing anything more investigation at all
do we have any other points of
clarification for our officers members
no in that case we don't have to debate
who would like to kick us off oh hang on
do you have another one
okay councilman
um the conservative at the back
we can see there on that photograph
that's
that's that's coming down isn't it but
it's not part of this application but
that's
not as part of this application but it's
been approved recently on another
application um approved only in october
this year
for um for it to be demolished and a new
extension
um abutting um the
range here i don't know if you can see
my cursor yeah um
it will be in that corner there the new
extension and that's been approved
thank you
okay in that case if there are no more
questions and points clarification we
will move into the debate who would like
to kick us off
cancer mills
thanks mr chairman yes i i was asking
these questions because
uh
[Music]
once
we
there's the refusal was because of the
um
so panels on the roof and because it's
listed here as soon as that and yet
we've got a fairly relatively new
conservatory on the back there that it's
not you know it's
it seems to be improved um
and i uh
i i
can't to be honest i can't see uh why
we're refusing
the roof um panels at the same time
approving that conservatory i mean they
both got the
same yeah okay that's what i think
anyway thank you
it's worth noting that obviously that
application is a separate platform we
have to consider on their own memory i i
do realize that don't you have the
benefit of the view of what has been i i
understand thank you so we have to
consider it on its own merits um council
dixon please
thank you chairman i'm looking at page
32. um
center of the page nppf recognizes the
significance of heritage assets
describing them as an irreplaceable
resource
which should be conserved in a manner
appropriate to their significance
i'm looking at this property and i'm not
sure if there's any significance to it i
appreciate its grade two listed
but as councilor mills and we can all
see it's been knocked about and had
various extensions and additions and
amendments over time
and then it goes on in that same
paragraph
this sentiment is mirrored in cs 8 of
the course strategy that assets should
be protected and enhanced
i would actually argue that
solar panels will enhance
that property
might not enhance it visually but it
will enhance it by way of generation of
electricity
so to my mind
i am supportive of the panels being
permitted
is that a proposal
i would propose that we grant yes
chairman okay we need to be clear on
your reasons for
going against officer recommendation
i'll come back to you on that cancer
adam signal first
thank you i'm happy to second that for
um and uh for the reasons that the
council dickson put forward um i think
it is in the parliament that i like
counselor rock said he's sort of not
disagreeing with protecting heritage
assets and i think the work that's gone
into this is is
um is useful but yeah we have to have a
forward momentum when considering this
type of application
um and particularly the the this
case in particular with with the
existing changes that have been made to
it you know the dormer and things like
that i think we can consider the
um the public benefit to
increase the renewable generation of
energy um it does outweigh the harm to
this particular one uh so i'm very happy
to second and support thanks
okay thank you very much council curtis
nothing further to add
okay council jennings
as i've spoken about it before i'm very
much in favor of solar panels
um
[Music]
and i know that
if you are going to make any changes to
uh listed buildings it has to be
sensitive
um i think if this has been on the front
of the building or visible and what i
appreciate that
whether it's visible or not
it doesn't affect the damage or harm it
does to a listed building
however it has to be done sensitively
and by not having any on the front
that to me does go along the sensitive
line let's say i'm very much in favor of
all the solar panels
that's that's what where i'm moving
towards
okay thank you very much anyone else
like to speak at this point
no okay so we have a proposal and a
second day um dale you've heard the
reasons that have been put forward are
you
comfortable that those reasons have been
clearly articulated and would you mind
repeating them so that we all understand
your interpretation of them as well
yes thank you chairman um
i think what i'm hearing from members is
that they've
understood the essence of the report
they've understood that it's uh
important to balance the impact on the
significance of the listed building
against the public benefits of the
renewable energy and i think i'm hearing
that they're giving great weight to the
amount of renewable energy that this
proposal will generate and that they
feel that that great weight that great
public benefit
will outweigh the harm to the listed
building um
it's not for me to comment on that
that's what i'm hearing from members uh
and that is within their
uh remit
to to reach that conclusion so i i
that's the reason i'm here in german
i think i'll also add to that and
correct me if i'm wrong cancer dixon
also referred to the uh extent of um
extensions that have been made and have
been approved um
[Music]
i think higgledy piggledy is a word i
read in here somewhere i might well
maybe i've just that's in my head but
the uh the style and the layout of that
in the back of the house actually uh is
already in that manner so uh that has
also been considered i think we need to
add that and help me with that
because
there have been alterations to the
dwelling which have caused it harm in
the past
um how does that
lead on
to i think the work i'm not clear what
what
justification that gives you
i think it's the the point is that the
consideration has been given to the fact
that that has happened it's not in
itself a reason to overcome but it isn't
a sort of additional thought okay thank
you that is what i heard am i am i right
in saying that
i would basically say that those
additional extensions in the past have
reduced the significance of that listed
building
okay
and chairman we'll do some reasons for
your agreement
i'm fine with that yeah
that condition okay
yeah so we're happy so the usual
the usual
um
conditions and then we can agree any
additionals yes it's unlikely to be
anything remarkable it'll be start date
and um in accordance with the plans and
structural surveys someone mentioned
yeah
right now structural assessment yeah
okay so as proposed dixon you're happy
to move forward happy counselor adam
okay in that case um the proposal uh
that's been seconded is to grant
application 2101 699 fuel for the
reasons given could have a show of hands
for all those in favor please
animus um so therefore committee
resolves to grant application twenty one
zero one six nine nine ful and one at
tree barn in warmington
okay
we will now move on to i'll just put
i do apologize i've read the wrong thing
we haven't resolved to grant on that
tree barn we have resolved to grant
application 2100 496 lbc old toft bridge
street and fenney compton i apologize i
read the wrong piece of paper
we will now however
hear walnut tree barn which is
application 2101 699 ful our presenting
officer is uh paul thompson um who will
join us now so paul whenever you're
already do feel free to start
thank you chair
hello again
the
presentation should be on screen now
uh this is
the outskirts of warmington we are in
the cotswolds area of outstanding
natural beauty and the site is the black
dot there a little bit closer
in
and we can see it outlined in red there
green dotted lines are footpaths and the
settlement of warmington and its
accompanying conservation area within
the purple boundary
over to the top right
the walnut tree barn itself
as you can see just there is a grade two
listed building it is one of five listed
field barns across the district and is
uh unique amongst those five for its uh
particular features which are very
specific to the local area um this is
the site plan as proposed
it's a new dwelling
which would face the listed barn which
is off to the right there
um replace the gable end of that and the
rear elevation
of the
detached garage
a new access is proposed i say new it's
reopened in in theory but the as you'll
see in that photo shortly the uh
it's not really visible at present it's
it's been dormant for a while
uh this is the dwelling that's proposed
this is the listed barn
this is the listed barn from about where
the
gable end of the new dwelling closest to
the road would be
across the gardens in between
this is a view towards the
proposed access which rather proves my
point i think
um
and this finally is the view towards
the rest of where the the new dwelling
would be
um the
the proposal is
contrary to our
um
policy on self-built dwellings and local
needs dwellings in that it doesn't
immediately join the village
um furthermore the
conservation officer has objected
um and hence on those grounds i
recommend that we refuse planning
permission chair
paul thank you very much um i will pull
forward our first speaker on this item
who is councillor mark burstle chairman
of warmington parish council
good evening and welcome thank you for
your patience
i think you've probably got an idea of
the drill so you will have three minutes
i will give you a 30 second warning as
soon as you're ready set and comfortable
if you press the button in the middle it
will turn red and feel free to start
so why is the planning officer
recommending refusal
part way down page 42 of your briefing
notes he says in respect to policy as10
while the proposed dwelling does appear
to meet an identified local need
it would be cited neither within nor
adjacent to a village
this is simply wrong
it is less than half a mile walk from
the church
almost exactly the same distance as the
properties along village road
it's within very easy walking distance
of the centre of the village
even bill budd with his severe
disability can and often does walk into
the village hall the pub or to visit
friends
the planning officer is wrong in this
assertion and is also wrong when he
refers to the proposed building as being
of unsustainable type and location
sustainability is at the heart of the
design of the building and there's
nothing wrong with its location
warrington alaska has apparent published
parish plan supported by a housing needs
survey
which has been formally adopted by
stratfor district council
bill's condition falls precisely
into the need identified in the survey
and this is confirmed by the letter of
support from wrcc which is in your files
again the bungalow that bill wants to
build is precisely the type of
development that was endorsed by the
parish plan
he has gone to great lengths to design
the bungalow to reflect the style of old
local animal barns and to be as energy
efficient as possible
bill grew up in warmington he moved away
to pursue a successful career in the
merchant navy
only to be forced out of that by a
terrible disease
myelin myeloma i beg your pardon there's
no cure and it's gradually crippling him
his father gifted him part of the garden
in his will expressly so he can build
for himself his own self-contained and
specially adapted bungalow to enable him
to live a full and independent life
within the community he loves
and be within reach of support from his
family
and his friends that piece of garden not
open farmland has now been separated
legally from walnut tree barn and is
registered in bill's name with the land
registry
bill submitted full details of his
medical condition to the planning
officer who rejected these of being of
no relevance to the planning application
i would argue that on the contrary
they are a very great relevance because
they clearly demonstrate need
i submit that this need should be the
overriding consideration 30 seconds
thank you this application has the full
support of the parish council and as can
be seen by the unprecedented numbers of
letters of support and the strong
turnout here from friends and neighbors
there is very strong local support
this is exactly what policy as 10
requires and i urge you to grant the
application
to the best of my knowledge there's
currently no property anywhere in our
parish which is specially adapted for
disa disabled needs
allowing this application will mean that
in future this specially adapted
bungalow will be there for others after
bill can no longer make use of it thank
you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our counselor
please
no
okay in that case counselor thank you
very much for your time this evening
while you are very kindly cleaning the
microphone on the table for us i will
call forward our next speaker is mr andy
wilkins our agent um and mr bud the
applicant
um now uh if you would like to take a
seat either side of the one in the
middle please um that way we can
absolutely apologize
difficult that's right you take as much
time as you need don't you worry
is there a hole in the top
thank you very much
i will now do the housekeeping
you can see if you could fix your mask
again before you make your way back that
would be great thank you
okay so i believe uh mr wilkins you will
be doing the speaking um and we spud
you're here to answer questions is that
correct
okay in that case miss wilkins um you'll
have three minutes 30 second warning you
know the drill whenever you're ready
feel free to start
thank you good evening ladies and
gentlemen my name is andy wilkins i
speak on behalf of bill budd who is on
my left and here to answer any questions
you may have regarding his need for the
dwelling
i trust that you safely received my
email earlier this week which sets out
the important and relevant information
over and above that contained within the
committee report
this is an application where you have
the full support of the world member the
parish council and the local community
this is not an application that anybody
wants to make nor is it an application
that is simple to determine but this is
an application of such importance that
is essential that you have you have
provided you are provided with the
background mr budd's condition
living in purpose-built dda
accommodation close to his carer family
the myeloma clinic is an absolute
necessity
purpose-built accommodation reduces the
pressure on doctor surgeries and the nhs
precisely because it is purpose-built
planning law makes it clear that
personal hardship can be a material
consideration in exceptional cases
this is such an exceptional and unique
case
mr bud has gone to great lengths to
ensure that the proposal is as
sensitively designed and highly
sustainable as possible
it will not detract attention away from
the main listed barn conversion itself
it has been designed to appear as an old
cart shed which will sit ancillary to
the main barn the impact on the setting
of the listed building will be neutral
the proposal utilizes local materials
and is for an energy efficient low
carbon home with high green credentials
including solar panels and ground and
air source heat pumps well in excess of
the building regulations
it will be zero carbon ready for when
the grid is decarbonized
the application addresses foursquare a
local need as established by the
warwickshire rural housing parish need
survey the whole purpose of the housing
needs survey is to identify and then
address a need such as this
otherwise why bother with the surveys
your policy on local needs housing sets
four important requirements
one have the support of the local
community
tick
two respond to an identified need tick
three be available to people with a
local connection to the parish tick
four be small scale tick
all of these are clearly met the only
harm is due to the location of the site
which is not immediately adjacent to the
village 30 seconds we accept that the
building proposed will be around for a
long time however the harm by virtue of
location is modest given the
environmental credentials of the
building and provision of features such
as ev charging
against this there are compelling
personal circumstances that will allow
bill bud to remain in the community in
which he has lived since a six-month-old
child close to his family and carer and
in purpose-built accommodation
we submit that this is an exceptional
case with wholehearted community support
these personal factors outweigh the
modest harm to policy please approve
this application thank you
thank you thank you very much mr wilkins
members do we have any questions
either for mr wilkins or for our
applicant mr councillor dixon please
mr wilkins apart from indicated
exceptional i think you also used the
word unique case
could you possibly expand upon that
um
planning law makes it clear that
personal hardship can be considered as a
material consideration
um
in exceptional cases
we see this as being an exceptional case
no i suppose not unique but exceptional
okay
any other questions members for either
our applicant or for the agent
no okay gentlemen in that case thank you
very much for your time this evening i
can see you're already cleaning up for
your phones yourself so thank you very
much if you could press the button again
just to turn the microphone off please
mrs thank you very much
marvelous okay um uh now our next
speaker is cancer fielding cat's feeling
if you want to make your way to the
center table for me please
once you've plugged yourself in
you're on full charge
okay so you will have five minutes i
will give you a 30 second warning you've
asked for the planning officer to put a
google map up because i'm going to read
through the number of different aspects
of the village okay uh
just bear with me a second
paulie paula hopefully you can still
hear us um would you mind bringing up
the google maps that cancer filling is
referring to please
certainly bear with me
thank you so much no problem
i hope my time hasn't started it's
almost done cancer phone
right
okay so casper whenever you're already
starting to feel free thank you
wilmington parish comprises the villages
of ascot if you can show where oscar is
in relation to warmington
warmington
the parish is not considered an lsv but
it comprises a church pub two shops
carpenters butchers and the national
herb center his main carrier runs piled
which
a hardware and garden repair business
which is only 400 yards away it is
therefore difficult
where it to be set as a
built up area boundary
because of the
width of the
other the parish
cancer fielding i'm just going i've
stopped your times don't panic
do you want to take your mask off um at
the moment it's muffling you a little
bit more than uh we would like so sorry
so long as it doesn't pull the hearing
aids off there we
go my apologies no problem your time has
been stopped so as soon as you start
again i will start again this proposal
meets two major features that are
fundamental this application the first
is the housing needs survey which if uh
uh paul thompson could put up one of the
items identified was bungalows which the
scheme provides as part of the parish
plan a housing needs survey was
uh conducted by wrcc
uh in 2016. this is up on the screen
when it gets to it and as if you can
read it
but it does refer to three one bedroom
bungalows and one four bedroom bungalows
none have been built
the second is allowing the elderly and
infirm to live within their own
environment as recommended by the nhs
and sdc
thus by granting this approval it would
help
to meet the needs of a popular member of
the community he has 29 letters of
support and four no objections
the family home warner tree barn is on
several levels this makes it very
difficult for a person with limited
mobility to get around
the cotswold conservation board have not
objected
the only
consulting that has objected is the
conservation officer both the parish
council and i
support this proposal
the planning officer's comments with
regards to public transport for local
needs are correct the applique applicant
is a popular member of the community and
can rely on neighbours to take him to
and from the hospital
the nearest neighbor is 400 yards away
from his property and for the last three
years this neighbor has been supportive
and help
to
the application following the father the
death of his father
the applicant is happy to sign a 106
agreement which in time will provide
additional accommodation for farm
workers or members of the community or
as you have been told for others who
have this an infirmity
the bungalow is designed to meet
stratford's environmental requirements
and sustainability for somebody with
this gentleman's ailments
the planning officer has listed core
strategy policies and he feels
that he feels are relevant cs1
this is
uh an application should meet the
positive
meet with a positive approach
and you can see all of these on page 47.
cs9 hi
high quality initiative will be
encouraged where reflects the
and complements the immediate local
surround environment and
maximizes sustainability
this property also meets cs15f
development it's restricted to a
small-scale community-led scheme which
must
meet an identified requirement by the
community
again
section g supports its proposal also the
requirements of cs15 refer to
the
residential development under sections
four and five
cs11
the aunb
the aonb are happy for developments
providing they do not affect the
environment that they are built in
i do not agree with the officer's
comments to refuse this application both
the parish wrcc
with
um with it
thus i would ask you to grant it one of
the things you can see in that letter
from wrcc
is the fact that it doesn't the building
does not need to be within the
built up area boundary or the parish and
also she refers to
the sarah brook taylor a self-built
development of this nature which is part
of
the
planning
um
policy that is a section whatever it is
but uh that is where i rest my case i
believe this should be granted and i ask
you to grant it
thank you very much councillor members
do we have any questions for our ward
member please
no
okay in that case cancer fielding if you
could do a little housekeeping and make
your way back to your seat i'd be much
appreciated
right in that case we have no more
speakers we'll move to a point of
clarification for officers councillor
dixon first please
thank you chairman
paul um on the page 41 the conservation
officer objection less than substantial
harm to the setting of the listed barn
due to sighting scale and design
features
do we have more detail as to the
thoughts of the conservation officer
please
because obviously that is very succinct
but further on
page 45
right at the very foot of that
the design and access statement
submitted with the application refers
that great care and attention has been
taken to ensure that the proposed new
dwelling will not be imposing or
detracting
from the main listed barn but i am
afraid that that design fails
dramatically in this regard
well obviously there's a definite
difference of opinion between the
conservation officer planning officer
and the applicant um do we have
something from the conservation officer
other than that one short sentence
please paul
uh counselor his comments are available
in full online i can read them out if
that would help
if you wouldn't mind please paul
absolutely
uh
it goes into a considerable amount of
detail on the history of the uh of the
building
the uh
element regarding uh
the proposal itself
is shorter
uh it begins
a historic background historic
farmsteads and their buildings make a
major contribution to the richly varied
character of the countryside and
illustrate the long history of farming
and settlement in the english landscape
field barns and out farms are set within
the fields away from the main farmstead
they saved on this is still history i
think we can probably
skip over that
um
the barn affected by the proposed new
dwellings located close to camp lane and
the village of warmington it has a sense
of isolation being cited within a field
network the os plan of 1885 shows that
the setting was open with the barn sat
adjacent to a track and field boundary
being and being and within a large field
typically it is built of local stone
with three bays with a central full
height wagon bay and a steep roof of
slate the attached cow house is small
and subservient in scale to the barn the
isolation form type and star reinforces
the building's rural historic and
agricultural identity and maintains it
as a landmark building within the
countryside
the proposed dwelling would be seen
close to the barn within its grounds the
building is single story but has a
relatively large footprint with a
driving parking area in the foreground
the style alludes more to an urban
architect architectural approach and
contrasts widely from the context
overall the composition would severely
compromise the impact of the barn in the
landscape and would detract and compete
with detect from and compete with it
consequently it is considered that the
proposal would be a detrimental to the
barnes context rare distinctive identity
and dominance in a rural scene it would
not preserve the barn setting unless the
substantial harm would be caused
comments in there
chairman i might be able to cast a
little more light on to that if it's
helpful if paul could show us uh the
slides of the the elevations of the
proposed dwelling and the photographs of
the barn
so if members would just
take in from that the characteristics of
the barn
the proportions of the roof to the walls
the uh overhang of the roof
of the walls
um and and the overall size and then
look at the next picture which is of the
barn
i hope i don't have to spell out the
differences but i'll point you to some
of the more obvious ones
um the the roof
is a much larger proportion of the uh
elevation
of the barn than it is of the um
proposed dwelling because the roof is a
much steeper pitch
so the proportions of the barn appear
narrower and taller
it has a very very different character
so if members were persuaded that in
principle this dwelling was acceptable
nonetheless in detail the character of
the proposed dwelling which has large
overhanging eaves as you can see there
there are no overhanging eaves
yeah it has none of the characteristics
of the barn except a passing similarity
of masonry
uh and i i think
that's what lies at the root of the the
comments you've heard from the
conservation officer as well as all the
the other points that he made thank you
chair thank you um remember we have any
more questions cancer curtis please
thank you um paul you had a photo or
showing
the
uh barn from the proposed site of this
new build thank you um
can you that looks i don't know is it
200 meters away can you give us a
distance from the new from the barn to
new build
it's it's certainly less than uh 200
meters i can give you a
precise distance if you prefer to bear
with me momentarily just roughly i mean
uh
i would say more on the order of
about 50 meters
right okay
and there are no windows
in the barn that
are sort of overlooking the new site are
there
that's correct counselor thank you thank
you
casa melz yeah thanks mr paul
the
materials to be used
uh are the same
materials for the
the barn yes the local stonework is
proposing
yeah we control that with the condition
of course
and i can see that the barn has uh in
the past been altered and i've taken
because it got um yeah
so
sorry sorry to jump in the the structure
if if you're referring to this structure
at this end yeah where i'm indicating
that's that's a cow shed that's
wouldn't it wouldn't be contemporaneous
with the original bomb but it certainly
has a fair vintage
uh and the um i can see some french
windows there that's uh
i've recently added um probably not an
original feature counselor no no thanks
that's what i'm getting at thank you
okay anyone else with any further
questions at this point um if not i'll
dive in with one uh paul we heard from
um i think both the parish council and
the agent um that in certain
circumstances exceptional medical um
circumstances can be considered to
overcome certain levels of harm i'm not
familiar with that are you familiar with
that could you enlighten us further if
you are
and tell us what consideration you've
given to it if indeed you are
or has
uh well the the planning practice
guidance um
typically says that the private um
private considerations
don't normally
outweigh
the public um benefits and harms which
are what
we're here to
to determine really as planning officers
um that of course conversely indicates
that there are some circumstances in
exceptional circumstances in which they
could so
whilst it doesn't plus i'm not aware of
any provision that specifically states
that
by
um
by considering what's actually written
there the the it leaves space for there
to be occasional exceptional
circumstances in which
um
personal circumstances are are
acceptable and if dale wants to come in
on that
um to be honest chair i think that's a
full answer
well done paul um
and something else that's rattling in my
mind i'm not sure if this is possible or
not um
are there circumstances or do you think
it would be reasonable
uh or possible for us to condition a tie
to um the applicant as the sole occupier
and on
uh him ceasing to occupy
uh for the building to be removed in the
area reinstated
um
this is one that ross might want to
chime in on but um
personal personal conditions are
deprecated by um the planning practice
guidance
um
because it's a self build and or local
need dwelling depending on
exactly which way we want to cut it it
would have to be subject to a legal
agreement section 106 agreement in any
case um to
to for him to be the um occupant for at
least three years and or for it to be
permanently available or in the first
instance at least for um people with a
local connection so that would achieve
the same if result with
um rather less uh controversy in
planning terms completely that way
okay thank you ross are you uh if you're
able to comment on that as well please
disaster that'd be great
yeah i think um i i don't think um a
condition tying
the dwelling to a particular person and
then requiring its demolition
um when that person is no longer there i
don't think that would be a reasonable
condition sure
okay simple answer to a simple question
thank you very much um members do we
have any other questions at this point
for officers in that case let's open up
to debate who would like to kick us off
councillor mills
well
thanks mr chairman yeah um
i i do know uh this um walnut tree barn
and only from uh from from the road um
the
paul says it's isolated this um
i can't see how it's isolated it's not
like it's in the middle of a field uh
and you won't see it from the roadway
that's that that's for certain
and
i think these are exceptional
circumstances i really do uh
you you've got support from the um
parish council you've got support from
i think 29 letters of uh support
um
these are exceptional circumstances mr
chairman and um
i i would go for for grant on this mr
chairman thank you
is that a proposal it is a proposal when
we get to i need to be very clear on
your reasons for going against the
officer's recommendation and the um the
policy
council foreman
thank you um i agree with cancer mills i
am prepared to second his proposal
um
my father had this condition
so i do know that it is medical
there are absolutely special
circumstances here that for enable us to
grant and i think the applicant did say
that he was prepared to sign a 106
application
agreement anyway when they were meeting
in their presentation so yeah i am
prepared to second your proposal council
emails
okay thank you very much performance
counselor curtis um thank you i mean
just looking at policy as 10
um if we're looking for a reason to
enable us to approve this
small scale scheme for housing
employment to meet a need identified by
a local community
um so i thought there is something there
that would give us scope
okay any other members wishing to speak
at this point
okay uh councilman is the proposer to
grant um could you please outline very
clearly your reasons for going against
policy that has been set out in the
recommendation
yes mr chairman uh
to be honest purely on his exceptional
circumstances um we have and chatham
here who
is in need of this
um i
personally i don't think it it
interferes with um the barn that that's
already there uh it is not isolated as
the um
as planned obviously stated because not
right in the middle of a field
um
yes mr chairman i it's this these
exceptional circumstances i would say
thank you
i do i do need planning reasons um
[Music]
i'm trying to think of the best way to
sum up what you've just said ultimately
so looking at uh
reason for refusal number two which
specifically looks at the greatly listed
barn and heritage
uh your
view is
that this doesn't cause harm
to that and therefore overcomes reason
number two
reason number one
uh is in relation to isolation um and it
being outside the build superior
boundary
it it's up to us as individuals it it
that i'm speaking cancer mills
it's up to us to decide whether we
believe it to be outside a built up area
boundary or whether it's isolated and
the picture you can see now i believe
that purple line is the built up area
boundary it could well be the
conservation area but it's
my personal view is that this is not in
the built-up area boundary
but if you're content
to put put that
uh this is not an isolated dwelling
we can put that
i can't support that so on that basis i
would be abstaining from your proposal
um
i think that is that
those are the reasons ultimately is that
right
just bear with me while i read number
three and remind myself
okay so by overcoming one and two in the
way that you have number three naturally
falls away
um
i just want to make it clear that i
i'm i'm uncomfortable with this proposal
um
on the basis of
policy and it sets in my opinion that's
a dangerous president the reason i'm
abstaining it's self-evident that there
are exceptional circumstances here and i
feel very uncomfortable um
putting
the applicant in the position that he's
in
we are tied by
our policy so we have to be very
comfortable that the proposal that has
been put
does in fact overcome that um
uh
those reasons
cancer adam
thanks chairman um just on the subject
of isolation i think
well
i would
say that there's more than one sort way
to define that there's isolation in
terms of
physically outside than a built up area
boundary but that it could
still not be isolated from the community
that is clearly in support of
the the applications before us so
although it isn't
within the sort of boundary on the map
there is a more holistic
um way of viewing that which is slightly
albeit slightly harder to define in
terms of
um the records that we may have but that
that's how i would read isolation in
being that essentially as i think it was
the parish council noted it's um half
mile to the church sort of thing i think
that
in my mind overcomes that from my
personal point of view of of how to read
isolation
uh just wondering if that might help um
also i was wondering if um counselor
mills might consider the points that
counselor curtis made in regard to as10
just to strengthen the resolve of his
proposal
councilmembers are you happy with that
would you like to be reminded by
councillor curtis
um policy ais policy thank you chair um
foxy as10
um
community um small it allows small-scale
schemes for housing
so for so forth
to meet a need identified by a local
community and i think clearly here we
have
support for a need that has been
identified by the local community thank
you chair
okay
dale would you like to just briefly go
through all that game for us just so
that everyone is clear of what's on the
table and the reasons for it i would
thank you chair um
i think probably preface what i'm about
to say with a a reference back to the
the mppf where it tells you that you
should make decisions in accordance with
the uh development plan unless material
circumstances indicate otherwise and i
think members have been indicating that
there are material circumstances that
they think do indicate otherwise in this
instance
so i think i think that's possibly your
starting point although i haven't
actually heard you say that today i
think that's the the sense of what's
been coming from you
and the material circumstances that i
think you see are this gentleman's
exceptional medical needs and his local
connection
um
what i've also heard
is that you feel that he represents a
local need in accordance with as10 now i
have to say that
our normal approach to local needs is
that they're identified by the parish
council or or some other such body by
way of survey
and we don't establish local needs on
the basis that someone applies and says
they have a local need
but that is obviously your decision to
make if you wish
um i've also heard you say that you
don't feel that the site is isolated
from the village
um although it is outside the any built
up any village boundary um because it is
closely related to the village it isn't
in your view isolated
um what i have heard very little on
is the issue of harm to the listed
building and the issue of the the design
point that's in in point two i think
councillor mills said he didn't feel
that he interfered with the barn but
i've not heard very much more on that
and i think it would be really helpful
if you could
bolster that for me
and then i think i'd have a complete
understanding i think specifically
counselor mills and i think isomized
this for him said that um
uh it causes no harm to that listed
building
um
is that fair
council dixon
i would concur with that view i thought
that the sufficient distance between the
proposed building and the uh the listed
bar was sufficient that would be limited
harm if any as such
but um
gail has just been
minded that the housing needs survey
report in 2016 did that mention
the requirement for this local needs
because obviously it's listed there as a
material consideration
and uh it was pointed out and i just
wondered if briefly while we're looking
at
the reasons to assist whether or not we
could have that
slide that
counts the field and produce which was
was at the wrcc
letter and i just wondered if that's the
one if that might assist as well yeah um
chairman to help me answer that question
can i uh
ask paul whether he has any insights
that i don't have
the quick answer to all of these
questions is that the
the dwelling does
um
meet an identified local need
that would has been identified in the
normal way the the sole issue is the
location in that it's not within or
adjacent to the village that's that's
the only respect in which it doesn't
meet the self-build or local needs
policies
thank you for that help paul
you're happy with that
i'm trying to get straight in my mind
you talked about material circumstances
at the start which i'm glad you included
because that very much specifically
makes this about this site and this
application so it doesn't set a
precedent
those material circumstances and my
right in thinking those materials
material circumstances can overcome the
fact that
one might consider this to be uh an
isolated dwelling
a simple yes or no would be good
then you can have yes
that helps me greatly
okay
we have a proposal it has been seconded
by councillor foreman for the reasons
given um could we please have a show of
hands for those in condition
conditions in section 186
thank you ross
can we have some conditions
usual conditions
i have nothing prepared to the usual
conditions um
do members
wish a section 106 obligation and if so
in what sense and what form
in what way do they want to limit the
occupancy of the dwelling um
local need as i understand that as i
understand it we would need to do that
through self-built and local need anyway
yeah yeah that would be very call
um agricultural need as well
um
trying to find it in my notes but i'm
sure he mentioned agricultural need
i'm looking at andy wilkins while you're
looking at that and cancer adam see well
they asked him to come in now
no did i miss just miss that hang on
i'll i'll get cancer i don't have
something i think just um to maybe try
and allay some of the concerns over the
heritage of the barn would landscaping
be
one the landscaping would be on the um
uh conditions anyway but would maybe a
more specific one in terms of
i just wasn't sure whether that was
something that we might want a closer
look on just for to to satisfy that
particular thing or the
if it's just covered by usual ones then
that might be fine if there's something
specific you want on the fact that we've
said um we the
the proposal is that there is no harm
identified i don't think it's necessary
unless you have anything specific but
landscaping in that case no audition
will almost certainly be on that um the
106 will cover um the
self-build and
[Music]
occupancy and local need so i'm
comfortable with that
cancer kendall
thank you chair just very quickly to
confirm with that could we remove the
permitted development rights on this as
well or would that automatically be
removed
because of these sectors oh look so
we'd have to have a reason to withdraw
permitted development rights chairman i
can't currently see a reason to withdraw
them
uh do members see one
i don't only that i'd want to see it
preserved as i don't know
i would prefer to see it gone but okay
if there's no other reason or so can't
think of what harm it would cause
it's extending the building further i
don't know the harm's been done
well okay
it's yeah
okay are we happy we've got the 106 and
the conditions
done ross i think we're happy aren't we
something coming through from paul
looking looking at this
i'm happy that with the 106 he had to
secure local connection and self build
paul suggested ross that um as it's
contrary to policy but permitted on
personal circumstances that would be
justify removing permitted development
rights
how do you feel about that
well yeah that's what i wanted to do i
think it should i think you should
remove them
because it might be my view from you
preserve this in aspect as it is and
anything further would be changes with a
separate application that's what i'm
saying i think what we're seeing before
it's acceptable for all the reasons that
have been stated but i wouldn't want to
see lots of small incremental changes
allowed
i'm prepared to support that i'm
prepared to support that um so you have
a view
i just think your your consideration
about removal of pd rights should be for
reasons of impact
on the setting and the listed building
really um rather than any question of
personal circumstances is you know is it
is there a justification to remove
pd rights for those reasons
yes i i i
i think i'd say yes given exactly what
we've just been saying about the um
listed building any further whatever the
permitted development was hypothetically
come forward approach or whatever i
think that would change the nature of
that building that we're looking at and
that could negatively impact the listed
building i agree with you and that's
exactly what i was about to say so yes
on that basis removal of pd
so sorry but to clarify that that would
be extensions and porches
any enlargement of the building
any changes
yes
yeah anything that physically changes
not saying new windows
yeah yes
exactly any changes that i think any
changes page any changes
okay
i think
i think we're there
you're all happy now um you've got what
you need corrector
okay in that case we can now move to a
vote could i please have a show of hands
for all those in favor of granting
permission for the reasons given with
the conditions given and the 106.
unanimous oh no sorry no it's not
seven four after those against
and abstentions
in that case council therefore resolves
to grant application twenty one zero one
six six six nine nine ful one at tree
barn
for the reasons that have been set out
fantastic right let's move to our final
item for the evening which is
application 2102 472 ful and uh at the
same time 2102 473 lbc which is the
cottage on the green in warmington
presenting officers once again paul
thompson paul whenever you're ready over
to you
thanks again chair
uh
we're staying in warmington uh we're
gonna go a little closer into the
village this time
uh to the green in fact this is a grade
two listed cottage uh one of a row
um proposed is a rear extension there
are also some uh alterations to the
fenestration and
on the front elevation but the case
officer
doesn't object to those however the
extension at the rear
which looks like this existing
elevations at the top and proposed
at the bottom um if we compare elevation
three with the northwest elevation
that's your easiest indicator of of the
the scale of the extension
here's what it looks like currently uh
it's a small sort of glass length that
will be demolished
as part of the proposal which will
extend above the eaves line and obscure
this
ground floor window
to the right
that's looking at it towards the
neighbor's property
the extension
if you recall the site plan will extend
further rearwards than this
and yeah that's a that's another view
that's um
on the strength of the uh the scale and
the design and the fenestration of the
extension the case officer recommends
that we refuse uh planning permission
enlisted building consent due to the
harm to the listed building chair thank
you
well thank you very much indeed um we
will call forward our first speaker on
this item who is uh miss jilly keith
is that right
marvelous come on forward come on if you
want to sit in the middle um
i don't know how the microphones have
ended up in the places they have
accounts of feeling make a mess of my
room um do you want to grab the
microphone to your left and bring it
onto your desk it has been cleaned get
it see it getting cleaned early on now
you'll have three minutes and i'll give
you a 30 second warning if you stay
seated for questions afterwards please
do um whenever you're comfortable set
and ready to go if you press the button
in the middle it will turn red and as
soon as you start speaking i will start
the timer okay so over to you whenever
you're comfortable
button in the middle
it'll go red yeah you're on so whenever
you're ready
um i sold my house in scotland and moved
down to warwickshire to be closer to my
three children they love to visit me in
warmington but as the property only has
two bedrooms it is very difficult to
have family get-togethers
therefore i was hoping to add a small
bedroom and replace the leaking
conservatory as part of minor planning
of space downstairs i'm keen to maintain
the ethos of this unspoiled village and
the character of the cottage and feel my
plans to extend are practical and
sympathetic
the conservation officer raised various
concerns about the proposals
he is concerned about
the scale of the extension yet i feel it
is modest and proportionate to the size
of the cottage
it replaces a single story conservatory
in the same location
neighboring properties show examples of
much larger additions with rear
elevations including a variety of
projections into their rare gardens
the new extension has a much lower ridge
height than the cottage and will
therefore be read as subservient
the conservation officer refers to the
rear of the property being mostly intact
and that it can be appreciated despite
the addition of the conservatory
the new extension is a simple vernacular
form and will only result in one
additional opening giving access at
first floor level
the stonework at the back will be
exposed within the extension showing the
original openings and historic changes
allowing the original design and form to
be appreciated
internalizing the kitchen window is
raised as a concern
this window has already been moved in
the past and patched with rather
incongruous red brick
that's the first photograph
he mentioned that the level of the first
floor window accentuates the scale of
the extension
this can easily be addressed by lowering
it to echo existing windows
he goes on to say that the large ground
floor aperture is also of concern even
though it provides a view of the rear
wall from the garden
a feature of the existing conservatory
that the conservation officer supports
the small conservation roof lights do
not detract from the roof scape and are
evident in many historic building
improvements providing natural light in
the building reducing the need for
artificial light there are many such
roof lights evident around the village
to summarize my aims to sensitively
extend are
30 seconds to provide space for my
family to be together to maintain the
character while bringing the cottage in
line with contemporary living
the picturesque front overlooking the
iconic green will remain unaltered apart
from the double glazed windows made from
wood to match the originals
i'm going to skip on it the cottage has
been altered through time the front door
has been moved according to old
photographs photograph
2 shows
the old position of the front door i'm
afraid i'm going to have to ask you to
wrap up if you don't mind please okay
historical council heritage are very
important but should be sensitively
weighed against the issues impacting our
environment
where possible changes should be made to
reduce these adverse effects caused by
inefficient heating and poor insulation
thank you very much indeed thank you
members do we have any questions from
steve please
counselor mills
thank you very much good evening and
you did send your presentation that
other
um properties along there have been
extended
yes
would that be
immediate to your on both sides from my
rear garden you can see extensions they
have extended um
so that they are not original
no okay thank you i think the property
to the right is not listed but property
to the left is
if looking from the ground okay okay
okay we've had an answer to that
question does anyone else have any other
questions they would like to meet
no miss keith thank you very much for
your patience and your time this evening
thanks if you wouldn't mind giving the
desk and the microphone a quick wipe
down with the yeah sorry with the watson
there we go and if you can press the
button in the middle it will turn it off
again
marvelous thank you very much and while
you're doing that i think uh council
feeling is all set ready to go so just
bear with us cancer feeling when when
keith uh exits the chair you can then
come forward
how's it feeling do please make your way
forward
and once again when you're plugged in
and on charge
um you'll have five minutes 30 second
warning stay seated for questions
afterwards
otherwise when you're ready do feel free
to start
could the officer put up the picture
photograph from the rear of the building
please
paul would you mind bringing up the
photo of the rear of the building please
thank you very much right the cottage on
the green uh and casper and john take
your mask off
and my hearing aids there we go
sorry about that it's all right don't
get flustered you take as much time as
you need
it's a cursive curse of old age
um right the cottage on the green
was too small cottage that have been
amalgamated into one dwelling i suspect
the original house had a thatch roof the
proposal is to bring the property up to
21st century and it is yet another
alteration to this property in the
architect's report he refers to the fact
that the timber
the timbers will not be affected the
conservatory at the rear is a typical
block botched structure that leaks both
rain water into the property and heat
out i go along with the planning
office's design
and
statement as on page
63
as a result she says that i find the
proposal to accord with policies cs 9
and 20
of the core strategy
and is in keeping with the local
and acceptable form of the development
location in con
in constructing the extension the
applicant has observed the properties on
either side both of which
have this typical structure the
applicant needs another bedroom and the
proposal provides this together with
improving
the accommodation on the ground floor
which will do away with this unsightly
conservatory
cs
uh stratford require properties to be
brought up to the current
insulation standards to preserve and
improve their carbon footprint
adopting csa to the course strategy
states that it will be
will be given to protect and enhance the
wide range of historical and cultural
assets that contribute to the character
and identity of the district proposals
which could lead to substantial harm or
lesses of the significance of the design
asset will only be permitted
where the public benefits outweigh the
harm
cs 8 does not state heritage decisions
are taken in the best interest of the
heritage asset and not in the best
interest of any current owner
whilst this
has implications in recent decisions by
the conservation officer where he where
he has refused to allow heritage assets
to be affected in any way shape or form
this completely reverses the planning
policy
that is not stated anywhere by sdc and
one could argue it goes against cs1
sustainable development
in addition
the in the decision being taken in the
interest of heritage assets this is
extremely concerning given cs2
and sdc's commitment to all it can to
mitigate climate change
therefore this is in direct
contradiction to the cs policies and its
stated commitments
for me the whole
the cell problem
centers around how sdc in
interprets
public benefit and how it weighs up
against less than substantial harm as
csh states where a development proposal
will lead to less than substantial harm
to
to the significance of a designed
heritage asset this harm can be
justified weighed against the public
benefit of the proposal including
securing optimum and viable use
the submitted heritage statement which
the conservation has chosen to ignore is
not mentioned in the committee report
that
that states neither the extension or the
alteration will cause significant harm
to the listed cottage or it's sitting we
will need
we will feel it
we feel it preserves the character and
the visual appearance of existing
buildings on the site
also including is a heritage statement
which sets out quite clearly the degree
the l of less than significant harm is
minimal and is largely reversible
on this basis when the minimal harm is
weighed against the public benefit of
climate change and sustainable
construction as specified in the com
committee report together with most of
the working
being reversible the conclusion should
be the application is granted
i rest my case
counselor thank you very much members do
we have any questions for cancer filming
no
case rested thank you very much cancer
fielding uh if you could i can clean up
after yourself that'd be great okay
members do any questions for officers
points clarification please
council mills
thanks mr um paul can the the
photograph if you could show me the
again at the back of the conservatory
sort of side on no
that's it
um how much further into the garden will
the new um
development be extension well done
thanks
couldn't think of the word it's getting
late
um
well we can
measure it precisely i don't have the
figure to hand
um
but this this drawing gives you
something of an idea and possibly uh
this one as well
if you compare where
the rear elevation is there
and the rear elevation there you can see
it comes
almost to halfway along that building
uh compared to no more than about
a fifth
quarter or a fifth
um if you if you'd like to bear with me
i can give you a precise figure
please
yeah okay
you having much joy there paul
i'll take that as bear with me
about that ladies and gents uh about 1.4
meters further along
okay happy council miles
council curtis please
thanks jeff and
paul really just following on from
council mills
sort of point in another way um if we
look at this plan that we've got up
the
the the the block of grey that is
to the through towards the top of the
screen
um yes that one uh the next one
three
yes
that one to the top
next one up
that's it thank you
that is is that the two-story extension
of the adjoining
property
so if
on yes there
yeah that's that that's correct council
because it's that structure there
so i think from what you said
the proposed new extension at the back
of the that we're looking at this
evening would not extend
as far as the existing
extension on the adjoining property
would that be correct
that's my reading of the plans
counseling
thank you
casa dixon please
thank you chairman paul can you put up
the slide please which showed the
position of the various listed buildings
particularly i was wondering if the one
that we've just referred to
is a listed building as well
it's not that's this that's this
building here
okay any further questions push
clarification counselor adam
were you was your microphone on there
turns out uh chancellor adams microphone
didn't respond to his press so he'll ask
his question again sorry about that
um the building on the other side that
appears to be attached to the
applicant's um property
um
it looks yeah that one it on the plan it
looks like that sort of
has an l shape as well that kicks back
is is that
a two-story building i know i noticed
that's
listed as well but i'm trying to gather
a sort of sense of the form of the the
building that's attached to it
it's a good question and one i'm afraid
i don't have the answer to as i wasn't
the case officer and i didn't have any
uh photos in that direction i can have a
quick hunt and see if there were any
there again i'm going to prevail on your
patients
can you see that on screen we
we can right that's that two-story
structure there
so
okay so unless we have any other
questions or of clarification for our
officers we'll move into the debate do
any more questions last chance
no let's move into the debate who would
like to kick us off
start picking on people council mills
are you going oh casting again oh dear
oh dear
thank you mr chairman um
i have to say
that the
conservative back does look pretty darn
tatty um
and
i believe this uh new accenture would
improve that i'm just looking at the
um
officer's report um
about the landscape impact on aonb
um
he's saying there'd be no harmful impact
on the character of aomb
um
and he also says on this on page 63 i
consider the proposed development is in
keeping
with the locality and acceptable form of
development in this location so
um
as you know i always go look at these
properties um
it can't be seen i mean from obviously
from from the green you can't you won't
be able to see it
um and i don't feel as any harm none mr
chairman
and i don't think a big improvement was
there thank you
is that a proposal
oh gosh i'll go okay i'll go for that
yeah i'll come back to you for your
reasons in a second thank you council
curses the reasons council meals is
outlined i'd be happy to second that
proposal if we can come back
anyone else like speak
i'm not minded to support it i'm minding
to support the case officer uh whilst i
have sympathy in that
the existing extension is clearly tatty
and rundown and in need of replacing
i believe that this is a demonstrably
larger extension um and would form a
substantial block of built form in that
area um so i i am in agreement with the
case officer in this particular instance
but that is a personal view cancer
kendall yeah i think i just echo what
you've said i'm not against the
principle of some sort of development
here but i think what is being proposed
for us
is too big and for that and that's
exactly what you've said for me so if
some element of i don't know single
story or something like that i could be
more open to this it's a very big
development and it does change the
character of that listed building
considerably
thank you very much kendall i'm on that
basis i'm going to propose that we do um
refuse for the reasons that have been
given um are you willing to second now
of course we have had a proposal that
has been seconded to grants we must hear
that one first before we do that will
anyone else like to speak
council jennings first
paul would you mind bringing that photo
up that shows the
correct it shows the um the neighbor to
the right when you're looking at the
rear of the property please
yeah other side
sorry bear with me caught me unprepared
because
that's right sorry yes you it was the
the very last photo you brought up and
it was of that's it
that's and that's a listed building as
well that's obviously an extension which
has been put on there
okay anything further to add
such a yeah
cancer journey is there anything else
you want to add before i move to cancer
dixon no cancer dixon
before you go on now
thank you chairman uh given that we've
obviously got two members here who are
concerned regarding the extent of the
proposed extension
do we paul have a floor plan
because obviously
uh if uh
we think it's too large
could we actually
not become
could the applicant in future put
something forward which would meet their
needs but not be quite so
in
anyone can put anything they want in as
an application absolutely
whether we grant it or not is another
question indeed i was wondering how how
what is the floor plan that's so much
bigger here
we have a proposal to refuse oh sorry to
grant forgive me that has been seconded
can you clarify for me the reasons that
you uh would go against the officer's
recommendation yes mr chairman um
i feel that there isn't any harm uh to
the um
locality as as what the
um officer says in his statement uh
he says in keeping with the locality
um in accordance with policy cs9
um
and says the proposed development will
be classed as small scale and therefore
satellite has been no harmful impact on
the character of aomb so
yes mr chairman i'll um say it it has no
harm as far as i i'm concerned
um
ultimately in your opinion it has no
harm and the sizes of an appropriate
size
i would stress that
as you've pointed out is harm to ammb is
what you're referring to rather than
listed building uh but um i understand
that you are putting that there is no
harm um and the size of scars
appropriate council curse is there
anything else you want to add i think
we've got an argument but no i
no i think you know the context of the
other buildings okay
let's move then to a vote so the
proposal is to now we have to take these
independently
um i believe so uh the first this is a
proposal on application twenty one zero
two four seven two fu l uh it poses a
grant for the reasons given um the usual
conditions nothing else you wanna add
could i have a show of hands for those
in favor of granting please
three three those against
one two three those abstaining
two two i get the casting vote i will
maintain that i will not be supporting
your grant so
we have also i'm going to assume that
that will be the same result for the lbc
do i need to go through the lbc as well
i think so yes okay we'll do the same
for the rbc so glad joe have hands in
favor of granting the lbc for the
reasons given those against
three and abstentions
two three three did you vote who are we
missing four
that was the rbc
we can this is for the list of building
consent so we've done the full
application this is for the lbc so 21
02473 lbc
the proposed the proposal is to grant
for the reasons that you guys set out
could we have a show of hands in favor
of granting the lbc
there we go great goes against
three abstentions
two two once again i'll use my casting
vote to overturn that so we have a
casper proposal which is to refuse the
application for the reasons listed in
the report could i please this is for
the full application 21-0-2-4-7-2-f-u-l
could i show of hands for those in favor
of refusal please
three those against
three those abstentions
two two
casting votes refuse
twenty one zero two four seven three l b
c to refuse the reasons given in the
report clever show of hands for refusal
this three
and there's against refusal
three abstentions
two casting votes refuse so
committee has therefore resolved to
refuse applications 2102 472 ful and 21
02 473 lbc for the reasons given
remember that is our final application
of the evening i don't believe there is
any urgent business there is not um it
is our last
planning committee for the year so thank
you all members for your time commitment
throughout the year thank you to all our
officers as well for their time help and
commitment throughout the year um and of
course all of our speakers it leads me
to wish everyone a very merry christmas
and a happy new year we will see you in
2022.
thank you very much meeting closed